merci président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président chers collègues
alors j'ai deux questions
à poser à Monsieur le Ministre une sur
l'employage et une sur la vie des
étudiants alors d'abord leur paillage un
article de l'ordonnance reformant le
code minier prévoit désormais
d'attribuer des sites exploités
illégalement à des opérateurs légaux par
une procédure administrative simplifiée
à mon avis c'est accès facilité peut
être efficace dans la lutte menée contre
les orpailleurs illégaux toutefois signé
par Emmanuel Macron dans l'entre-deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle ce
nouvel article du droit minier n'est
toujours pas appliqué faute du décret
d'application donc ma question
savez-vous monsieur le ministre qu'on se
décret d'application sera-t-il signé
s'agissant des étudiants de la vie
étudiante alors en 2013 les étudiants et
les lycées en guyanais ont manifesté
pour la création d'une université
autonome en Guyane après des années à
dépendre des Antilles pourtant six ans
après l'inauguration de l'université
Guyane nous étudions dépendants corps du
CROUS situés en Guadeloupe vous pouvez
donc imaginer les difficultés
rencontrées par nos étudiants dont les
dossiers sont traités par des personnes
qui
ignorent tout de la réalité guyanaise et
c'est dans le sens de l'histoire que la
Guyane dispose d'un CROUS autonome à
l'image de l'université donc pour le
moment c'est un clouz et une université
de plein exercice se mériterait un CROUS
sur leur paillage
il est clair que la meilleure lutte mais
vous l'avez dit et je le redis fortement
que la meilleure lutte contre leur
paillage illégal est un orpaillage légal
ça sera une protection de
l'environnement une protection contre
les voyous
le
décret d'application toujours aller moi
je râle aussi sur la durée comme vous on
me l'annonce avant le 1er janvier 2024
j'ai regardé pourquoi ça dure si
longtemps et bon on va essayer d'y
travailler en tout cas
il nous faut aider l'année prochaine
première expérimentation permettra de
tester des modalités pratiques de mise
en oeuvre sur des sites de friche
il nous faut organiser à la fois
d'aller chercher de l'or pour être clair
manière raisonnée raisonnable il nous
faudra travailler aussi sur la fiscalité
ce doit être me semble-t-il une
ressource forte de la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane c'est
une illustration de ce qu'on peut faire
en termes d'adaptation outre-mer par
exemple sur le col minier et c'est la
seule vraie réponse à leur paillage
illégal je suis convaincu de cela
sur le CROUS
un CROUS autonome quand on est à 1600 km
soit à peu près deux fois la distance
Paris - Marseille
d'avoir un CROUS autonome assez 100 km
ça me semble pas idiot ça relève pas de
ma compétence mais ce que je vous
promets c'est de saisir ma collègue la
ministre
en charge des univers